in 2016 more than 23 million people
watched each episode of Game of Thrones
eager to find out which intricate plots
would unfold on screen but did you know
some of the most interesting storylines
actually take place behind the scenes
let's take a closer spoiler filled look
at the untold truth of Game of Thrones
pop quiz Hot Shots author george RR
martin had long been reluctant to adapt
his novel series a Song of Ice and Fire
because he didn't want the on-screen
version to tarnish the brilliance of his
books so when David Benioff and DB Weiss
approached him for HBO Martin agreed on
one condition
they had to answer one question without
using the wizard game the hell are you
talking about actually Martin asked them
who they believed Jon Snow's true
parents were when Benioff and Weiss gave
the correct answer Martin gave his
blessing in return well the rest of the
world finally learned the truth during
the season 6 finale that Jon Snow is
really the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark it's not hard to admire
Benioff and Weiss for sussing out the
truth years ago
HBO nearly canceled it before it aired
believe it or not even after solving
Martin's riddle Benioff and Weiss his
first pass at the pilots episode wasn't
very good
HBO executives and producers were so
unhappy they almost ended the show
before it could even begin in an
interview
JB Weiss explained that after watching
it one of the HBO head honchos put it
bluntly you guys have a massive problem
the script was rewritten about 90% of
the pilot was reshot with a new director
and the showrunners also made major
changes to the cast the role of Daenerys
Targaryen was recast substituting emilia
clarke for actress Tamzin merchant
Catelyn Stark was recast to bringing in
Michelle Fairley for Jennifer Hale the
original pilot has today never aired and
that's a shame for plenty of reasons
george RR martin explained that he had a
cameo during the nurse's wedding scene
it was sad to say left on the cutting
room floor i was a pentoshi nobleman in
the background wearing a gigantic hat
lady stoneheart if you're a Game of
Thrones fan who's never read the books
you might not realize that one of the
franchise's most popular characters
hasn't even
shown up on screen yet in the novels the
red wedding isn't the end of the story
for doomed Catelyn Stark after she's
killed the phrase throw her body into
the river where it flows for three days
before being recovered by beric
Dondarrion and the Brotherhood without
banners Lord beric magically resurrector
at the cost of his own life he dies as
the spark of life passes to lady Catelyn
when she Rises her skin is gray her
hairs turned brittle and white and her
faces a massive shredded wounds filled
with clotted black blood she cannot
speak because the bloody bastards cut
her throat too deep for that but she
remembers cuts in Stark is dead and Lady
Stoneheart reign has begun she becomes
the new leader of the Brotherhood and
directs them in a bloody campaign of
vengeance against Lannisters and phrase
when learning Klingons just isn't enough
although Martin only created a
rudimentary outline for the fictional
languages of his novel Game of Thrones
producers required a much broader
vocabulary to use on the show they turn
to language creation society founder
David J Peterson and he created entire
languages for both Dothraki and Valyrian
including grammatical rules and
pronunciation guides if you'd like to
learn either language yourself direct
your web browser to the appropriately
named Dothraki org the red wedding
really happened well the red wedding
sort of really happened author george RR
martin frequently draws from real
history for his books and a notably
nasty incident in scottish history
served as inspiration for the infamous
red wedding in season three in a 15th
century incident that will be later
known as the black dinner william the
sixteen-year-old Earl of Douglas and his
ten year old brother were invited to a
feast with James a second the child king
of Scotland the King's advisers dragged
the young girl and his brothers outside
the castle gave them a mock trial and
then beheaded them both the Lannisters
and there occurred
similarly the purple wedding where King
Joffrey meets his maker was based on a
real incident to the poisoning and death
of England's Prince Eustace at a feast
in 1153 sometimes fans do the work while
Martin created a lush and vibrant Lee
detailed world in A Song of Ice and Fire
he does occasionally leave things out as
a result the showrunners sometimes have
to use their own imaginations or that of
to fill in the gaps in one prominent
example from season six the show's
costumers were tasked with creating a
sigil buckle for Howland Reed to wear
during the Tower of joy flashback scenes
Martha that described it in the books as
an alligator like lizard lion but he
never offered a complete description
luckily fans have been creating artwork
based on Martin's vision for years the
producers must have been impressed with
this image since it sure looks like it
was copied and pasted right onto Reed's
costume horsepower and bodybuilding in
season six during the breathtaking
cavalry charge at the Battle of the
bastards Jon Snow stands alone on the
battlefield as Ramsay Bolton and amber
horsemen right toward him at breakneck
speed but snows army suddenly rushes up
behind him igniting one of the show's
most impressive battle scenes if he
thought it had to be green-screen
trickery however you were wrong the
showrunners revealed in a
behind-the-scenes video that those were
dozens of real-life horses charging
Harrington at full gallop until the last
minute I was stood there facing off
against this cavalry charge which is
really scary we're a bit annoyed because
I think everyone's gonna think it was
CGI and it wasn't so now we know about
the horses but how do producers create
that impressive pile of bodies on the
battlefield during the battle the video
reveals that all the bodies were
actually life-size dummies not
computer-generated fakery the crew
acquired hundreds of mannequins dressed
them in appropriate house umber and
house Bolton armor then coated them in
mud and fake blood and piled them in a
gigantic heap even the dead horses among
the men are dummies equipped with
saddles now that's attention to detail
happy ending for lady one of the most
heartbreaking moments on Game of Thrones
came during season one when Prince
Joffrey orders the death of aiiah Starks
beloved direwolf when the Lannister
soldiers can't locate I as pets Queen
Cersei orders that Sansa style wolf lady
be killed instead thankfully lady or
rather the northern Inuit dog that
played her on-screen
got a happier ending in real life
actress sophie Turner bonded with the
animals and she adopted her more than
meets the eye in A Song of Ice and Fire
Daenerys Targaryen and her brother
Viserys have purple eyes and Game of
Thrones showrunners planned for them to
have them on the show as well
unfortunately the purple contacts
affected actress Emilia Clarke
so badly that producers decided to ditch
the contacts and reshoot the scenes of a
natural baby blues and that's not the
only eye-opening tale from the set i
astark has blinded during her training
with the faceless men and in order to
accurately portray the role actress
Maisie Williams wore completely opaque
sixteen millimeter thick contact lenses
for her speaking scenes and a pair with
only a pinhole in the center during
fight scenes a gift for hate until
Ramsay snow hit the screen during season
3 Joffrey Baratheon was perhaps the most
universally despised character on the
show which I disagree with he was the
best character by far Irish actor Jack
Gleeson did such a convincing job as a
sadistic boy king that Martin reportedly
sent him a note that read
congratulations on your marvellous
performance everyone hates you gee
thanks George thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
other cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]